urlaub trotz reisewarnung manche reisen
ab aber auch heute fliegen wieder
deutsche touristen nach mallorca
trauer in minsk in belarus gedenken
tausende des mannes der bei den
protesten gegen staatschef lukaschenko
getötet wurde
und ein sieg für die geschichtsbücher
bayern münchen deklassiert barcelona im
viertelfinale der champions league
8 zu 2
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers willkommen und guten
abend hinein zum überblick über diese
nachrichten samstag sport aber natürlich
auch mit dabei
mit norbert könig natürlich mit der
champions league genommen und wir
beginnen mitten in der hochsommerlichen
urlaubssaison mit den warnungen vor
corona risiken die das beliebteste
reiseland der deutschen getroffen haben
es gibt eine reisewarnung für ganz
spanien mit ausnahme der kanaren
das bedeutet kein reiseverbot aber die
regierung rät von einer reise dringend
ab noch sind 30.000 deutsche
pauschaltouristen allein auf den
balearen
die reisewarnung trifft alle die derzeit
in spanien urlaub machen und die die
erst noch fliegen wollten viele
pauschalreisen wurden gestrichen und
doch gingen auch heute wieder flieger
mit touristen von deutschland zum
beispiel nach mallorca julia schröder
mit den einzelheiten flughafen hannover
heute früh check-in nach mallorca
die reisewarnung für spanien und die
balearen schreckt die reisenden hier
nicht ab ich bin relativ entspannt ich
glaube auch dass die insel nicht
besonders voll sein wird bei mir ist
eigentlich alles gut meine braut
mulmiges gefühl wir müssen aber
hinkriegen weil wir in notartermin haben
auf mallorca offizielle reisewarnung das
heißt wer eine pauschalreise gebucht hat
kann kostenlos stornieren
auch die veranstalter werden reagieren
und geplante reisen von sich aus erst
mal absagen der größte deutsche anbieter
tui hat das schon getan
doch aktuell sind bereits rund 30.000
deutsche pauschalurlauber allein auf den
balearen der reise verband geht davon
aus dass die meisten auch bleiben werden
wer aber trotzdem beck will kommt auch
weg der kunde ist gut beraten wenn er
sich zeitnah mit dem reiseveranstalter
in verbindung setzt der wird
entsprechend wenn das gewünscht ist den
rücktransport entsprechend organisieren
der gesundheitsminister ist sich bewusst
dass eine reisewarnung gerade für
spanien einschneidend ist verteidigt sie
aber weil wir natürlich das
infektionsrisiko nach deutschland rein
reduzieren wollen deswegen ist es auch
kein reiseverbot
aber der klare hinweis wer aus spanien
zurück nach deutschland kehrt quarantäne
bis ein negatives testergebnis vorliegt
mit der neuen lage und der aussicht auf
quarantäne gehen die meisten urlauber
auf mallorca entspannt um
die entscheidung ist richtig
es seien alle getestet werden die
zurückkommen ich fühle mich eigentlich
hier schon sehr sicher im vergleich zu
deutschland einfach weil wenig los ist
und was sich gut aus dem weg gehen kann
alles andere als entspannt sind dagegen
all diejenigen die mit dem tourismus ihr
geld verdienen
die reisewarnung ist für sie ein herber
schlag da haben sie den einbruch vom
umsatz her kämpfen und überleben im
minimum das urlaubsgeschäft hat er sich
nach dem log down gerade erst angefangen
zu erholen
jetzt scheinen die aussichten schwer
zeiten denn je wir gehen live nach palma
de mallorca zu thorsten schaub brenner
thorsten guten abend wie ist denn die
situation jetzt im moment ist da so was
von hektischer abreise zu spüren oder er
alles ruhig
na ja in der tat gibt es urlauber die
jetzt prüfen ob sie ihren rückflug
vorziehen
einfach weil sie zu wenig zeit
eingeplant haben zwischen der rückkehr
und ersten arbeitstag und man muss ja
davon ausgehen wenn ich mich dann
getestet habe abtasten lassen in
deutschland dass dann einige tage
vergehen bis sich ein ergebnis habe
und insofern prüfen jetzt einige
urlauber die wir getroffen haben
ob sie ihren rückflug vorverlegen es
gibt auch noch musik am strand auf jeden
fall dass nach wie vor was bedeutet denn
so eine reisewarnung mitten im sommer
für die mallorquiner ja die mallorquina
die sind natürlich schockiert viele
verdienen mit im tourismus mit den
deutschen urlaubern ihr geld viele
gastronomen haben gehofft dass diese
saison wenigstens im september oktober
noch ein klein bisschen einnahmen herein
bringt diese hoffnung ist jetzt jäh
zerplatzt und es gibt noch eine zweite
sorge der mallorquiner und der menschen
die hier leben
denn es wird befürchtet dass die
mallorquinische inselregierung um die
zahlen der neuinfektionen zu senken
möglicherweise neue maßnahmen ergreift
und auf einem zweiten sehr strengen
lockdown hat hier auf mallorca wirklich
niemand lust aus palma thorsten schaub
brenner herzlichen dank und dann schauen
wir jetzt auf die lage in deutschland
1415 neuer corona infektionen etwas
weniger als gestern aber weiter auf
hohem niveau
nimmt man den durchschnitt der letzten
sieben tage dann ergeben sich 1080
ansteckungen pro tag gestern lag der
wert noch bei 1030 angesteckt getestet
und dann kein ergebnis bekommen so
erging es ja fast 1000 urlaubsheimkehrer
in bayern drei tage ist es her dass die
panne auffiel und noch immer ist nicht
klar ob inzwischen alle infizierten
bescheid wissen
die bekanntgabe wird von tag zu tag
verschoben jetzt soll es morgen
informationen geben
am mittwoch musste die bayerische
regierung einräumen dass testergebnisse
von insgesamt 44.000 menschen liegen
geblieben waren
menschen möglichst früh zu warnen dass
sie kontakt zu einem infizierten hatten
und sie sich selbst angesteckt haben
könnten
das soll ja die korona waren app leisten
vor fast genau zwei monaten haben 16
juni gingen sie an den start und ist
seither 17 millionen mal heruntergeladen
worden
was nichts darüber sagt wie viele
menschen sie tatsächlich nutzen
und das ist nicht das einzige problem
der apps wenn ricken christian bennefeld
kann signale der korona empfangen und
anzeigen der mathematiker aus hamburg
sieht damit wie viele andere handy
nutzer in seiner nähe die app aktiviert
haben
die selbst geschriebene software kann
sogar die sende stärke ermitteln die ist
mitunter stärker als wende und glas wir
saßen beim chinesen zu zweit um uns
herum waren keine anderen menschen
sichtbar und trotzdem hatten wir rund
zehn bluetooth kontakte zu anderen
corona wann apps das hat uns erstaunt da
hat ein schritt zur bennefeld
interessiert vor allem wie viele von den
17 millionen downloads der korona app
sind wirklich im einsatz sprich ist die
app ein erfolg oder haben einige oder
viele sie längst wieder gelöscht
sie zeichne ich das an was sein fahrzeug
sollte eigentlich das ist eigentlich der
grund weswegen ich sagte brauche ich
nicht freundlich ich finde es wichtig
dass man wenn man wird doch viel
unterwegs ist dass man weiß man ist auf
der sicheren seite mit der app ich habe
auch gehört dass es eigentlich nicht
funktioniert technische schwierigkeiten
wie solche abstürze schaffen
verunsicherung updates sollen fehler
beheben schaffen aber mitunter neue im
telekom handy labor in dresden läuft die
app daher auf so vielen verschiedenen
geräten wie möglich vor allem aber auf
älteren smartphones wird die app immer
wieder probleme bereiten
es ist schon interessant wie für
unterschiedliche devices ist ein markt
gibt und wie die auch regelmäßig auch
noch genutzt werden auch durchaus mit
älteren generationen auch das ist eine
herausforderung die wir ganz intensiv
mit mit apple google halt installieren
christian bennefeld versuch in hamburg
zeigt zudem es gibt regionen in denen
die app viel genutzt wird in der karte
rot dargestellt und manchen taucht sie
kaum auf smartphones auf es braucht wohl
noch mehr
vertrauen in die app so viel in der
sendung zum thema corona seit tagen
schauen wir auf die dramatische lage in
belarus den nachbarn von polen im osten
europas im ganzen land auch heute wieder
proteste gegen gewalt und willkür den
sechsten tag in folge in der hauptstadt
minsk versammeln sich tausende zur
trauerfeier für alexander trajkovski
einen getöteten demonstranten
und sie fordern den rücktritt des
staatschefs der nennt die proteste eine
bedrohung für belarus christian senn
berichtet es sind symbole der hoffnung
und des friedens am mittag sind im
ganzen land wie hier in der hauptstadt
minsk wieder tausende belarussen auf der
straße um friedlich ihren protest zu
zeigen gegen präsident lukaschenko die
gewalt und die so umstrittene wahl
ich fühle mich geehrt mit meinem volk
sehen sie wie viele menschen rauskommen
und alle haben strahlende gesichter alle
sind sich sicher dass wir praktisch
gewonnen haben
blumen und noch mehr blumen an der
u-bahn-station puschkin sky gedenken an
alexander terkowsky ein demonstrant der
hier in der nähe bei den protesten ums
leben kam
nach tagen der blutigen gewalt des
lukaschenko systems gegen die
demonstranten halten sich die
sicherheitskräfte seit gestern
auffallend zurück ich denke lukaschenko
ist zwar ein vollidiot aber er versteht
dass man das volk nicht mehr aufhalten
kann
wenn die festnahmen nicht aufhören ist
sein ende nahm langzeit präsident
lukaschenko warnte vor einem umsturz und
lehnt eine vermittlung aus dem ausland
ab aber er sucht hilfe in russland
telefonierte mit präsident putin seinem
verbündeten die verteidigung von belarus
ist heute nicht weniger wichtig als die
verteidigung des territoriums unserer
verbündeten
es sollte sind anderen ein beispiel sein
der kreml teilt mit putin und
lukaschenko seien zuversichtlich dass
die aktuellen schwierigkeiten in belarus
bald gelöst werden könnten wie bleibt
offen
in der stadt rottner im westen von
belarus wurden auf einem theater schon
flaggen ausgetauscht dort weht jetzt die
alte weiß rot weiße flagge von belarus
das zeichen der opposition deutschland
gebe zu wenig für das militär aus hat
us-präsident donald trump mehrfach
kritisiert und zuletzt entschieden
truppen abzuziehen als eine art
bestrafung die zusammenarbeit mit polen
dagegen will er ausbauen und konkret
heißt das von 36.000 us soldaten werden
12.000 aus deutschland abgezogen und
gleichzeitig wird in polen die truppe
von 4500 auf 5.500 aufgestockt den
vertrag dazu hat us-außenminister mike
pompeo heute in warschau unterzeichnet
tom bloch berichtet der us-soldat dein
freund und beschützer so volksnah zeigte
sich am nachmittag das militär in
warschau
nur wenige stunden nach dem politisch
alles besiegelt wurde
us-außenminister mike p und der
polnische verteidigungsminister marius
borg unterschrieben den für polen so
wichtigen vertrag für den polnischen
präsidenten angie du da weitaus mehr als
nur eine zahlenmäßige aufstockung der
truppen
es ist eine erweiterte garantie dass im
falle einer bedrohung unserer soldaten
schulter an schulter zusammenstehen und
jede mögliche bedrohung verteidiger für
polen sind die usa die schutzmacht vor
allem als abschreckung gegenüber
russland ist vor wenigen tagen gab es
gemeinsame übungen von polnischen und
us-truppen das abkommen verspricht nun
neben den 1000 zusätzlichen soldaten
mehr und eine modernere infrastruktur
für die us-armee die außerdem zugang zu
zusätzlichen militärischen einrichtungen
erhalten soll und der weltraum das
internet die falschinformationen das
abkommen das wir heute unterschrieben
haben wird uns die möglichkeit bieten
gegen jedes der probleme vorzugehen
dass die truppenverlegung die
strategischen gewichte in europa
verändert erwarten militärexperten nicht
unbedingt sie sehen eher die entwicklung
des die usa ihre präsenz in europa
verringert polen erhofft sich dennoch
eine deutliche stärkung der nato
ostflanke der tag heute ist nicht nur
eine bestätigung für das ohnehin enge
verhältnis zwischen warschau und
washington polen essbereich die bande
künftig noch enger zu knüpfen
während deutschland mit den amerikanern
in mehreren fragen über kreuz liegt will
polen beweisen dass es in europa der
beste und verlässlichste freund der usa
bleibt und auch im atomkonflikt mit iran
zieht der amerikanische präsident seinen
kurs durch da sind die usa zwar mit
einem resolutionsentwurf im uno
sicherheitsrat gescheitert sie wollten
dass das waffenembargo gegen iran
unbegrenzt verlängert wird
jetzt wollen die usa aber einen
speziellen mechanismus im atom deal
aktivieren und da mag damit automatisch
alle sanktionen die vor dem atom ob
kommen galten wieder in gang setzen
nach deutschland der gewitter regen der
letzten tage kann nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen hier bei uns herrscht
dürre und das seit mehr als zwei jahren
fast im gesamten land ist der boden zu
trocken schon in den hier orange
markierten regionen spricht man von
einer schweren dürre und je dunkler
desto dramatisch ist die zum beispiel im
harz wo früher grüne fichtenwälder waren
sind hektar weise baum friedhöfe
entstanden wie hagen nicolas zeigt
forstwirt meyer stork ist fassungslos
wenn er seinen wald bei offenburg sieht
die alten fichten sterben der
borkenkäfer hat sie befallen
diese fläche die jetzt vor uns liegt das
war wie gesagt letztes jahr noch
geschlossener dunkler wald die bäume
sind über 170 jahre alt das ist das ist
unglaublich was hier passiert ist
fast 100 hektar nadelwald hat der
forstwirt so in zwei jahren verloren der
fichtenwald im ostharz stirbt rasant
braun grau statt sattem grün eine fläche
der größe bremens sei schon geschädigt
schätzt der waldbesitzerverband wegen
der dürre können die bäume kein harz zur
abwehr des borkenkäfers mehr bilden um
seine ausbreitung zu bremsen werden
frisch vom käfer befallene bäume gefällt
zurückbleiben kahle flächen und
irritierte wanderer noch nie waren so
viele borkenkäfer auf dem weg da kommt
es nicht ordnung
das war wie eine wolke andauern
als es um kleine geschlüpfte heran voll
im nationalpark harz haben sich die
borkenkäfer schäden seit 2008 zehn
verzwanzigfacht der nationalpark sie
darin eine chance für den wandel zurück
zum ursprünglichen laubwald deswegen
werden wir in den nächsten jahren noch
buchen pflanzen
wir haben auch hier unter dem schutz
dieser anscheinend toten nutzlosen bäume
kleine buchen schon stehen weil so ein
alter fichtenwald toter fichtenwald hat
immer noch ganz gute ökologische
funktion forstwirt meyer stork muss
seine schäden alleine stemmen aufforsten
will auch er mit robusteren mischwald
bisher jedoch neuer wald steht werden
jahrzehnte vergehen unwetter helfen
gegen die dürre nicht wirklich die hat
es auch wieder gegeben in deutschland
unter anderem im münsterland und im
ruhrgebiet wie hier in dortmund die
regenmassen setzten ganze straßenzüge
unter wasser
autos blieben liegen und keller liefen
in nur wenigen minuten voll
auch in der nähe von bremen klickten die
böen bäume um die autobahn 1 musste in
beide richtungen gesperrt werden und vom
wetter über zum sport und zu dir ja mit
einem rauschenden fußball abend und
einem historischen dazu eine champions
league ja nur nicht abheben hat lautet
allerdings die devise für die bayern
nach dem traumhaften 8 zu 2 gegen den fc
barcelona das halbfinale gegen
manchester city oder olympique lyon am
mittwoch beginnt eben bei null zu null
die katalanen haben den totalschaden und
eine fassungslose fangemeinde buhrufe
bei der ankunft im hotel für messi und
co auch das noch verbale schmach für die
stars die sich nach der pleite sowieso
schon fühlen müssen wie geprügelte hunde
es ist wahr dass wir alle extrem
frustriert sind besonders für unsere
fans ist das alles sehr sehr schmerzhaft
spaniens sportpresse wird deutlich heute
von schock ist zu lesen von der großen
schande von barca von einer historischen
demütigung einem debakel dass
veränderungen im verein zur folge haben
muss
bayern spielt atemberaubend gegen den 26
maligen spanischen meister
es ist das torreichste spiel der
champions league geschichte 8 zu 2
bayern überrennt barcelona trotzdem
bremst trainer flick im anschluss die
euphorie das war unser ziel ja dass wir
heute ja einfach ins halbfinale kommen
und das haben wir beeindruckt auch
geschafft und deswegen sind wir alle
sehr sehr froh
ja wissen aber auch dass es noch ein
hartes stück arbeit ist am ende dann da
zu stehen wo wir gerne hin wollen aber
auch wenn das champions-league-finale
nächste woche sonntag das große ziel ist
ein bisschen feiern war schon erlaubt
gestern abend nach diesem imposanten
sieg pech für emanuel buchmann der
deutsche radprofi muss bei der dauphiné
rundfahrt nach einem sturz mit tiefen
schürfwunden aufgeben
den tagessieg auf der vorletzten etappe
feiert sein teamkollege lennart kemmler
und lewis hamilton eroberte in der
formel 1 qualifikation von barcelona zum
92 mal die pole position sebastian
vettel mit dem nächsten dämpfer
nur platz elf zwei tausendstel sekunden
fehlen sebastian vettel
von teil drei des qualifyings trotz
neuen chassis es alte probleme und
bleiben der frust team-konkurrenz schale
claire kämpft mit stumpfen waffen um die
zehn besten startplätze bei ihm spukt es
plötzlich im motor er ist nur neunter
startet morgen eine reihe vor den
deutschen ganz anders mercedes lewis
hamilton einen hauch schneller als
valtteri bottas beide staaten aus der
ersten reihe dahinter lauert max dass
daten drittschnellster derzeit der
einzig echte konkurrenz von mercedes
also in barcelona gewinnt vermutlich
kein deutschland schminke jetzt möchten
wir ihnen auch eine dame vorstellen
horst brooklyn new york
das ist an adele priori sie tanzt gerne
und viel mit ihren 107 jahren und sie
hat jetzt bereits zwei pandemien
überstanden gerade erst eine corona
infektion und als kleines mädchen vor
gut 100 jahren schon die spanische
grippe
da dürfte sie so ziemlich einmalig sein
auf diesem planeten
die erklärung der 107-jährigen für ein
langes leben und gute gesundheit
mediterrane diät und scharfe peperoni
viel olivenöl natürlich das wetter der
tag morgen beginnt mit viel sonne
ob wann und wo auch wieder gewitter
drohen das erfahren wir gleich von katja
horneffer ganz aktuell gibt es eine
lokale unwetter warnung für
niedersachsen
der kollege claus kleber hat den
neuesten stand der dinge im
heute-journal viertel vor elf morgen
gibt es uns wieder um punkt sieben danke
für heute und ihnen allen einen
angenehmen samstagabend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren wie
ungewöhnlich die aktuelle hitzewelle ist
zeigen diese zahlen im vieljährigen
klimatologischen mittel der jahre 1961
bis 1990 gab es in hamburg drei
hitzetage also tage mit einer
höchsttemperatur von über 30 grad
im vorläufigen klimamittel der jahre
1991 bis 2020 werden es sechs tage sein
und jetzt im aktuellen jahr gab es in
hamburg bereits bis einschließlich
gestern 11 hitzetage da kommen
wahrscheinlich noch einige dazu war es
auf jeden fall dazu kommt sind gewitter
und kräftige schauer und gewitter die
gab es ja heute vor allen dingen hier
zwischen dem emsland und dem bayerischen
wald und mit kräftigen schauern und
gewittern haben wir jetzt auch noch in
den nächsten ein zwei stunden zu tun
in der nacht lassen die mehr und mehr
nach dann locker das auf und es bildet
sich auch mal niebel oder dunst die
temperaturen sinken auf werte zwischen
20 und 12 grad und klettern dann morgen
recht einheitlich auf 27 bis 32 grad
der tag beginnt erstmal mit viel sonne
am mittag werden sich dann die ersten
wolken in den himmel bauschen und am
nachmittag reicht's dann im westen
wieder für unwetter für gewitter die mit
hagel platzregen und sturmböen verbunden
sind der schwerpunkt morgen westlich ist
niedersachsen nordrhein westfalen und
rheinland pfalz und sehr wechselhaft
startet dann auch die neue woche ist
wird ein wenig kühler schönen sonntag